مناخ سويديه شابه معروفه بجدليتها من وقت
ما بدات نشاطها وهي طفله لمراهقتها وحتى
الان في شبابها لها اسلوبها في الاحتجاج
الكثير ناس بتعارضوا وما بتحبوا اسم في
العناوين ولكن مو بسبب احتجاج ولا دعوه
لاحتجاج بخص التغير المناخي ولكن السبب
تغريده تغريده قديمه كانت نشرتها في عام
2018 التغريده كانت مشاركه فيها مقال
لموقع اسمه وعنوانها عالم او عالم مناخ
كبير البشريه ستنقرض ان لم نصلح التغير
المناخي بحلول 20 23 والتقرير بيشرح
تصريحات منسوبه لعالم كبير بيقول ان
البشريه لو ما وقفت استخدام الوقود
الاحفوري رح تنقرض خلال خمس سنوات يعني
السنه اللي نحن فيها الان ويبدو في ناس مع
دخلتنا 20 23
اثر في حسابها وبشويه اتضح انه قريتها
مساحه التغريده واخر مره انشافت في حسابها
كانت في سبعه الشهر عموما حبايب جريتا ما
قصروا فيها وعلى تويتر نزلوا تغريدات
ويقولوا لها فين التغريده وليش مسحتيها
واهو 20 23 جات ومنقرضنا يا للتذكير بس
مشاهدينا انه كثار من معارضين ما بينكروا
ابدا الاحتباس الحراري والخطورته لكن
شايفين جريتا يعني اوفر شويه